[Music]
welcome to the uplift get on in here we
have a great show for you today and a
great cast of characters starting with a
boy who went viral for his honest I mean
very honest Sandwich review what he's
doing now with his Newfound internet fan
we will tell you in just a bit and a
girl with a frightening diagnosis in two
years to live how she overcame the odds
and became a star
a mom with three kids who are losing
their Vision what she's doing to give
them a lifetime of visual memories oh
this is cool
she's doing it before it's too late and
then a boy who donated his own money to
make a wish so he could build something
special
and also we have a California cowboy
with a connection to a queen that's
right how the unlikely pair formed a
friendship all of that plus our most
heartwarming videos you just need to see
you are watching The Uplift
[Music]
hey what's up y'all I'm Nate Burleson
and this is the uplift the show that
lifts you up for the next 30 minutes now
kids are often the ones to lift us up
right they tend to say whatever is on
their mind and those unfiltered thoughts
end up being pretty funny our first
story is about a boy who became famous
for doing just that sharing what was on
his mind Caitlin okay has more
[Music]
that is not what do you expect a
kindergartner to say when they get off
the bus on their first day of school but
Abe and dege is an honest person
on the first day of kindergarten
good day
friends
[Music]
recess area small
nothing else lunch table sandwich
nothing else
foreign
you may be familiar with Abe he went
viral this year for that honest review
of his lunch his mom Ricky posts that
same terrible sandwich video every year
the difference what happened this year
is instead of just posting it to my
friends and my Instagram feeder and my
stories actually I posted it on Tick
Tock for the first time and then Tick
Tock did its thing and it really went
viral so now we know why Abe has become
known as the terrible sandwich kid but
what is the story behind the sandwich
I didn't realize I needed to pack Ava
sandwich because in our town
kindergarten is still half day and so I
thought the benefit of a half day is
that I didn't have to pack them a lunch
I was wrong we had nothing in the house
we can't send peanut butter in because
of the kids with the peanut allergies so
I came up with this idea to do a butter
and jelly sandwich
when I took a bite of it at school
really terrible sandwiches
he's now in fourth grade and that moment
has made him famous at at school I'll
definitely get recognized I hired
new bodyguards
I'm always running around with that
snack a sleeping crowds of children
after gaining attention for his
unexpected review even his mom decided
to turn the spotlight on others we
launched terrible sandwich.com as a way
of trying to raise funds and awareness
to fight childhood hunger it's a cause
that's close to our hearts and we wanted
to use this little moment in the
spotlight to try to give back and do
some good so we have terrible sandwich
merch coming out terrible sandwich by
the way and thanks for letting me know
merch thanks for letting me know halfway
the prophets go to Hungry children
all across I guess the world it went
viral for saying what's on his mind and
what's on his mind these days isn't
terrible at all how I feel about this
little time in Fame
it's I don't want all every single one
of me I want some of this funding for
someone else a country chilled like a
thousand millions billions of hungry
children around the world
I don't want everything going to me
[Music]
I'm not gonna lie to you if I hopped off
the bus and I told my mom that her
sandwich was terrible she's not gonna
like it not gonna like it at all she's
gonna look at me and say you better eat
what I make and you better like it
that's just how I grew up okay
four-year-old Celine received a
terrifying diagnosis as a baby given
just two years to live not only has she
overcome the odds she's now hitting the
runway and breaking down stereotypes CBS
Miami's Lisa Petrillo has the story
[Music]
four-year-old Celine demowski is busy
riding her unicorn at her mommy beach
condo as she gets ready to walk in a
very important fashion show I'm doing a
fashion show
are you excited
so what are you doing in the fashion
show I'm supposed to do a half turn as
Celine practices her turn her mom Amber
Joy Watkins tells us that when beautiful
Celine was just an infant she and her
husband Tom demowski felt something
wasn't quite right with her baby girl
she was about three months I noticed
that she wasn't you know rolling or
kicking or just doing some of the things
I saw other kids do in my mommy and me
yoga class at first her pediatrician
told her Celine was just fine but Amber
Joy could tell something was off a few
months later she was told to find a
neurologist right away the diagnosis SMA
or spinal muscular atrophy Celine has
the most severe type SMA Type 1 and it's
a disease that affects all muscles of
the body so gross motor it affects your
ability to swallow your ability to
breathe and just every muscle in the
bottom body similar to ALS a frightening
diagnosis that left her parents
understandably devastated and the life
expectancy left untreated is two years
so it was a very scary diagnosis but
soon there was hope I mean more than a
glimmer of hope at the time you were
told hey there there are these
treatments coming on the market and you
know we don't know a lot about them but
we're going to try them we're going to
try them clean is very fortunate to have
received treatment and that's why we are
here today so it's a game changer huge
lifesaver
Celine continues to get stronger in fact
she has big plans for the future what do
you want to be when you grow older a
doctor a doctor
or a chef either one of those are a
perfect choice
just last week to kick off New York
Fashion Week Celine and her mom and
others with CMA hit the runway wearing
designs they adapted with open Style Lab
the program is sponsored by Genentech as
part of the SMA my way program which was
built to support and raise awareness for
the SMA Community we are claiming our
space in the Fashion World letting
people know that there is a space for
disabled people watching Celine Walk The
Runway was a steal the show moment that
her mom hopes will help change long-held
stereotypes for Celine and others like
her I just want people to see that
Celine is fashionable and beautiful and
smart and beautiful and smart even with
SMA her walk in the runway is helping
people run themselves figuratively and
literally coming up three siblings
losing their Vision with a mom who
figured out a way to help them live the
life to the fullest
they say the best thing you can do is to
fill their visual memory
and they were talking about by reading
books and seeing pictures of elephant
and giraffes and books and and that's
when it clicked
plus our heartwarming videos you just
need to see stick around you are
watching The Uplift
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the uplift we now have
our heartwarming videos you just need to
see starting with this one taken at the
graduation ceremony for a t side
University in northern England
[Applause]
[Music]
I mean come on come on when you hear a
baby's voice you can't help but to smile
I love that video all right now take a
look at our next video where brother
meets his sister's boyfriend for the
first time
[Music]
Mr Bucket hat
hey buddy
are you gonna jump in my arms here
what's up buddy I can I crazy dream oh
hey buddy hey buddy he's like I had a
crazy dream so here's the deal that is
Nate who traveled from Chicago to
Nashville to meet his sister Lindsay's
boyfriend Lindsay told us that they did
FaceTime often before meeting in person
so clearly they hit it off oh I love
that video okay this next video shows a
boy named Junie on a field trip to a
fire station
Junior who is blind uh got to meet a
firefighter for the first time that
meant filling his uniform and gear
hearing the sounds his equipment made
and asking all of the questions that he
wanted his mom said it was his favorite
part of the field trip
all right how about one more
heartwarming video this one is from
Tatiana and Preston who are trying for
the first baby and we're about to look
at a pregnancy test check it out
look at that it's right there it's in
the middle yeah it's gonna say not
pregnant
oh my gosh
what if he says
babe
no way no way no way and now Tatiana and
Preston are parents to a beautiful
two-month-old named Ayanna
congratulations coming up meet a mom of
four who's staying positive Even though
three of her children are losing their
Vision what she's doing to make sure
they have full lives
plus the boy who got to make one wish
and chose to use it on something
selfless
[Music]
in the California cowboy who had a
special friendship with the queen yeah
the queen that one how they met decades
ago
foreign
[Music]
that is traveling the world for an
entire year and there's a good reason
for the epic journey Caitlin O'Kane has
the story
many moms dream of their children
growing up and seeing the world but when
three of her four kids started having
vision problems Edith Lemay learned that
their time to do that might be running
out her oldest child Mia started bumping
into things and was diagnosed with a
genetic disease known as retinitis
Pigmentosa what it does is that the
original dies the cylinder retina dies
over time and they lose their Shield of
vision so they're going to lose their
vision from the outside to the the
center and in the end they're gonna see
through it's like seeing through a straw
and there's a chance that they'll go
completely blind by midlife then her two
younger Sons started exhibiting the same
symptoms and she learned they had it too
of course it was devastating
um and you know when you have a kid you
you always have like an image of what
the future is going to be like and what
your future is going to be like and all
of a sudden you get that news and you
need to erase that and and think think
it think it over
and and it really it's a grieving
process she thought about teaching them
Braille but a specialist had another
suggestion and they said the best thing
you can do is to fill their visual
memory and they were talking about by
reading books and seeing pictures of
elephant and giraffes and books and and
that's when it clicked and like I'm not
gonna do that in books I'm gonna go see
them in real life in March they left
Canada and embarked on an Epic Journey
traveling the globe for a whole year
showing their kids the world before it
was too late
we spoke to them on their stop in Bali
they had already crossed Africa from
Namibia to Tanzania they visited turkey
and Mongolia and planned to work their
way through Asia Next
their kids they are excited about pretty
much anything don't move through it
um with the urgency of seeing things and
remembering things they don't think
about oh it might be the last
time I see that thing or they're really
in the moment and they enjoy it they
made a bucket list of things to do
together allowing each kid to see their
dreams come true so MIA loves horses so
she really wanted to
um go horseback riding and we did that
in Mongolia and she felt so free after
the the horseback riding she like had
tears in her eyes because she was so
happy that it was really beautiful to
see Colin what he wanted to do is to
sleep on a train so when we went on the
tazara in Tanzania
and we had like all our bunk beds in the
train and we slept being rocked by the
movement of the train it was super happy
and in the little one whenever the thing
you wanted to do is um he wanted to
drink juice on a camel that was really
specific and we thought it was so funny
and we we actually did when we were in
Mongolia we were in the camel riding and
we got a juice just for him just to take
a picture and he was super happy
Edith said her kids aren't only making
memories they're learning valuable life
lessons like focusing on the positive I
want them to know that any situation
that's hard it's temporary because
through their life they'll need lots of
Brazilians
because they're going to adapt to a
situation with their eyesight and then
like a few years or a few months later
they'll lose another chunk of their
eyesight and they'll need to
re-adapt and adapt again and and fall
and get back again every parent wants
the world for their kids and Edith gave
it to hers
all right you may have heard of little
free libraries where neighbors can leave
books for each other but what is a dog
Library
CBS Minnesota's Kirsten Mitchell
explains
when we walked by he found a bowl of
water and pretty much demolished the
entire thing on Wilson Street in
Northeast Minneapolis
I love dogs like Murphy are sniffing out
something special made just for them
pick up toys to pick up leashes to pick
up poop bags because everyone should
pick up their poop please it's a dog
Library where people can share old items
or take what they need thy neighbors had
come over with a little bouquet after
I'd lost Charlie just two and a half
weeks ago and we started talking about
getting things out that we could share
with other neighbor dogs that's when the
idea was Unleashed really cute dog
wallpaper
on the tile floor and will Mound got to
work fast about three days really just
yeah just watching around in the garage
besides the dog Library will Mound is
also known for his creative projects
around the neighborhood he's also made a
little free library and you'll find
these little wooden fairy doors speckled
all over the area it was one of the
first rounds of layoffs in the beginning
of the pandemic and it was hard to find
work at that time so
I just I needed something to do and it
was kind of my outlet it's not just a
love of dogs uniting these neighbors
it's the shared loss of losing a dog
over the past year we lost our dog
Harold a little over a year ago Dan and
Emily lost Hank yeah it's been nice
because I mean we all experienced it all
at the same time so we're kind of able
to like support each other a little bit
that way and Lisa lost Charlie their
names are now displayed on the library
it was very personal and very sweet for
me to see Charlie's name up there
there's just so much out there right now
that's negative so it's kind of nice to
feel something something new touching
the hearts and the new snouts on Wilson
Street everybody's getting new dogs now
so in Minneapolis Kirsten Mitchell WCCO
4 News
everyone's getting a dog but not me
honey a toy brosen did you see that see
those Smiles on their faces I'm talking
about the dogs and the people
all right coming up meet the boy who
received the Make-A-Wish and decided to
use it on something that could benefit
other children
what was his wish we'll tell you
plus the Cowboy and the queen how did
this pair form an unlikely friendship
I thought she was a groom I said nice to
meet you and I stepped back and I went
oh my god oh
you're the queen
and
yes last time I checked
[Music]
many children with critical illnesses
received the opportunity to choose a
Make-a-Wish Quinn Larson did something
unique with his CBS Minnesota's Susan
Elizabeth Littlefield has the story
life can be full of ups and downs the
Larson family knows it well their oldest
son Quinn fell from a window then got
meningitis he lost his hearing and
ability to speak but he never lost his
Drive I remember
distinctly when we first met Quinn in
2019 he was a kid with a dream and a
long shot goal he donated his own money
to make a wish to make the dream of an
accessible playground happen I think the
community raised
307 thousand dollars
just to make it happen
and the smallest right yeah Adam Quinn's
money and a grant from DNR and voila
what was once at cornfield is now a
field of dreams and then we built it and
they came and boy did they ever about
500 people showed up at Quinn's
playground the ground is wheelchair
accessible there's a resting spot for
kids with autism sign language art the
swings are accessible and the zip line
oh the zip line
when you're on the playground
so then he can be included with some of
the fun stuff you did this plan
you did that this is yours this is your
dream a dream realized in silence and
and strength actions speak louder than
words in Waconia Susan Elizabeth
Littlefield WCCO 4 News
I've said it before I'll say it again
kids are the purest of the pure
so when Queen Elizabeth died many
stories about her life came out
including one about an unlikely friend a
cowboy from California Mark Strassman is
with the story
and this is the Queen's hallway
improbably indelibly Monty Roberts
became Queen Elizabeth's Horseman and
more Her Majesty has treated me as if I
was a younger brother Roberts
revolutionized horse training taming
horses using a silent language of
kindness in 1989 the queen with her
Lifelong Love of horses invited him to
her stables at Windsor Castle I thought
she was a groom I said nice to meet you
and I stepped back and I went oh my god
oh
you're the queen
and
yes last time I checked handwritten
letters an annual Christmas greetings
framed their three decade relationship
did you consider her a friend I would
call her her majesty
but the friendship was deep did you ever
think to yourself what am I doing
hanging out
with her majesty only two or three times
a day
[Laughter]
and every night when I went to bed on
Monday Monty Roberts will go to the
funeral of a friend still in shock
I said no
what and I don't want to let her go
she's going to be with me every instant
that I'm alive a dark horse friendship
the California Cowboy and the Queen
the cowboy in the rest of the world did
not want to let her go but her Legacy
lasts forever that's our show I hope
this news in these stories into Joy the
pure joy brightened up your day and
lifted you right up
foreign